let's make mini apple cobbler perfect  for when you want a personal size  portion start by peeling apples you'll  want to use one Granny Smith in about  four honey crisp just make sure you have  two pounds in total slice into half inch  squares making sure pieces are even in  size then add apples and these  ingredients to a bowl then mix to  combine melt the butter in a skillet  then cook the apples for about five  minutes or until they begin to soften  make the cobbler topping by adding these  ingredients to a bowl whisk then blend  butter into the dry ingredients add  buttermilk and mix until you get a  crumble evenly distribute the apple  filling and crumble topping among four  seven ounce ramekins cover each Ramekin  with foil and bake in a preheated 375  degree oven for 25 minutes then remove  foil and cook for another 15 minutes  until golden brown serve with ice cream  and enjoy